So now let's talk about how to reduce the waste,
how to have fewer than 2 to the nth counters
and yet have a long history. So, we will talk
about the history-based predictor with shared counters. So again, the
motivation for this is that with N-bit history, the way
we've just seen it, we will need 2 to the
nth counters per entry, if we want to do things the
way we've just done them. And we also know that
for repeating patterns, only about N counters out of 2
to the N are really used. In reality we are
using about N plus 1, but basically the important thing
is that we are using the number of counters that is
proportional to the size of the history. But we need
to have 2 to the nth counters, because we don't
know which histories will be important. So the idea here
is to share these two-bit counters between entries instead of dedicating
2 to the nth two bit counters to each entry.
We will have a pool of two bit counters that
entries will then use, but it is possible that different
entries with different program counters and different histories end up
using the same two bit counter. So there is a
possibility of conflict, but if we have enough of these
two bit counters, because each entry really doesn't need too
many of them usually, we will have very few conflicts